لسنوات عديدة ، كان Instagram مكانًا لقائمة Wunderlist مليئة بصور الأشخاص الذين يستكشفون ويغامرون في جميع أنحاء العالم ، ولكن الآن مع انتشار جائحة فيروس كورونا على قدم وساق من داخل مرآب منزله بالخشب الرقائقي في سان فرانسيسكو في المرآب الخاص بي. يطلب من مستخدميه أن يفعلوا ما يفعله البقاء في المنزل ، ما هو الدور الذي تراه في Instagram في هذا العالم الجديد ، فنحن جميعًا نعيش في أشخاص يعملون من المنزل ، حيث يكون الأشخاص قلقون جدًا بشأن هذا الفيروس في المقام الأول ، ولكن أيضًا يشترون منزلًا قم بتوجيههم إلى معلومات دقيقة جيدة والآخرين لتجميع الأشخاص معًا ، أطلقنا ملصق البقاء في المنزل والذي سمح باستخدامه لإضافة ملصق يقول البقاء في المنزل لقصصك ، ثم أطلقنا قصة البقاء في المنزل والتي تظهر الجزء العلوي من Instagram ولكن إذا قمت بالنقر فوق ذلك ، يمكنك رؤية كل من استخدم هذا الملصق الذي تتابعه ، فقد يكون هناك أصدقاء ، فقد يكون هناك منشئون قد يكونون شخصيات عامة ولكن حاولوا تشجيع الناس على  في المنزل والبقاء
بأمان ، فإن العثور على معلومات دقيقة عبر الإنترنت
أثناء هذا الوباء هو مسألة حياة
أو موت
استجابةً لذلك ، نفذ Instagram
سياسات جديدة لمكافحة
المعلومات الخاطئة المتفشية. أعرف شيئًا واحدًا سيشير إليه
المراسلون والناشطون في كثير من
الأحيان بشكل خاص حول
التضليل المضلل ضد اللقاح وهو البحث
عندما يضع الأشخاص لقاحًا في شريط البحث ،
ستظهر بعض المعلومات الخاطئة ،
يبدو أنكم قد توصلتم إلى طريقة
لمعالجة المشكلة من خلال البحث حول
فيروس كورونا ، هل يمكنكم أن تشرحوا لنا كيف
يعمل ذلك ولماذا كان يمثل هذا
التحدي بالنسبة لـ Instagram لذلك  ما
فعلناه هو شيئان مختلفان كنا في
الواقع منذ أسبوع أو أسبوعين نضع
معلومات وروابط جيدة لأماكن مثل
علامات تصنيف CDC حيث فعلوا ذلك أكثر من 19 عامًا
وفيروس كورونا الذي هو في الواقع
البحث الأساسي عن الأشخاص بشكل عام ،
ويسعدني ذلك  نحن نقوم بذلك
في البحث ولكن إذا كنت صادقًا ،
أعتقد في الواقع أن البحث بشكل عام والنفث
مثلنا يحظى باهتمام كبير جدًا
لأنني  ليس شيئًا يفعله الأشخاص
وغالبًا ما يكون الأمر أكثر أهمية هو أن
يحصل الأشخاص على معلومات جيدة عندما يأتون
إلى التطبيق في المقام الأول أو أن
المعلومات الخاطئة لا تنتشر على
المنصة ولكننا اعتقدنا فقط أنه نظرًا
لمدى الوصول الذي قدمته منصتنا  ما مدى
شدة هذه الأزمة ومدى
جدية أننا أردنا اغتنام
الفرصة لتوجيه المزيد من الأشخاص نحو
المعلومات الجيدة وهو شيء
لا نفعله تقريبًا من حيث مجرد
وضع لافتة في الجزء العلوي من
Instagram وسيطبق الجميع ولكن  هذه
ظروف قصوى ولكن هذه
الإجراءات الجديدة لمعالجة
المعلومات الخاطئة عن فيروس كورونا تعني أن البروتوكولات الجديدة تنهي
تدريبات الموظفين ، وهذا ليس
وقتًا مثاليًا لكي يعمل آريان من المنزل ،
كل أنواع التحديات التي نحتاجها
للعمل من خلال
مقدار المخرجات التي يجب أن نتحملها بشكل عام.  القدرة على توقعها على
أساس شخصي ستنخفض فقط
ولا توجد طريقة للتغلب على ذلك ، لذلك
هناك أشخاص قد لا يكون عملهم في Instagram الآن غير موجود
كن معتدلاً ولكنهم
أخذوه نوعًا ما أثناء عملهم
من المنزل عبر شركة Facebook بأكملها على
الإطلاق ، حيث يوجد أشخاص يتطوعون ،
نحن نوظف المزيد من الأشخاص حيث يمكننا
من الأولوية ما هي التجربة مثل
إدارة واحدة من أفضل الشركات المعروفة
في العالم من المرآب الخاص بك ، إنها
رواية بسبب عدم وجود كلمة أفضل ، لقد
كانت صعبة ولكن لدي
أفضل بكثير من معظم الناس الذين أنا متأكد من ذلك ، لذا فأنا
أذكر نفسي بذلك